Hola Bienvenidos a economía de fin de
semana en France 24 hoy vamos a hablar
de un fenómeno que está ocurriendo en
Colombia y que muchos han llamado Guerra
de tasas de interés y para ellos saludó
en el estudio a nuestra editora
económica Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida cuéntenos de qué se trata
Hola Andrés Muchas gracias Pues Mire lo
que han hecho los bancos centrales de
casi todo el mundo para combatir el
fenómeno inflacionario es subir el costo
del endeudamiento agresivamente esto
para que la gente no consuma tanto y
generar una reducción de precios de
recordemos la ley de oferta y demanda
pero en Colombia el sector financiero
comenzó a fomentar todo lo contrario
concretamente varias instituciones
redujeron la tasa de interés en sus
productos más costosos y más usados que
son las tarjetas de crédito Aunque
ciertas condiciones existen para ello
por ejemplo no son todos los bancos
solamente algunos y de manera voluntaria
además hay restricciones o no
dependiendo de la entidad Por ejemplo en
algunos la reducción aplica solamente
para
tipos de tarjeta y con cupos específicos
o para compras en particular de bienes
de consumo básico esto no toca nos toca
el bolsillo a todos en plata blanca como
cambian las condiciones de crédito para
la gente lo primero que hay que saber
Andrés es que los intereses de la
tarjeta de crédito suelen ser los más
altos en Colombia hay un tope llamado la
tasa de usura que quiere decir que el
que cobre por encima de eso estaría
incurriendo en un delito ahora veamos
los bancos casi siempre están muy cerca
de ese tope que hoy es un poco más del
45% anual es decir que la tasa que se
paga mensualmente es la en las más de 15
millones de tarjetas de crédito
expedidas aunque esto depende del caso
por supuesto podría acercarse al 4%
mensual con la reducción que han
anunciado algunos bancos es se interesan
anual quedaría entre el 20 y el 25%, es
decir alrededor del 2% mensual pero si
bien Esto es un bálsamo para el bolsillo
de los consumidores también hay que
tener cautela con esta clase de
incentivos lo consultamos con angular
Rodríguez él es el vicepresidente de la
asociación Nacional de instituciones
financieras y eso nos dijo
es un tema de también ser conscientes y
darle si bien es una señal de apoyo a
los hogares colombianos una señal de
decir mire el sistema financiero es es
Sólido y tiene la capacidad de
de digamos otorgar la liquidez y la y
darle a los hogares colombianos la
liquidez necesaria para sus decisiones
de consumo lo que es importante es que
los hogares sean conscientes que este es
un año
de desaceleración económica es Claro que
los hogares colombianos en este año se
van a enfrentar también un mercado
laboral que va a tener
algunas restricciones y vamos a estar
digamos que va a ser complicado desde
ese punto de vista
tener unos unos niveles de ingreso altos
y asegurados para los hogares
colombianos entonces pues es un mensaje
también de de moderación y de y de
cautela y decir que las decisiones que
se tomen Al momento de hacer una compra
con la tarjeta de crédito sean
decisiones
informadas sean decisiones claras que se
tenga en cuenta Cuál va a ser el costo
financiero Daniela Entonces cómo se
interpreta que los bancos comerciales
bajen las tasas mientras los bancos
centrales la suben Pues esta puede ser
un arma de los consumidores también
podría ir en contra vía como le está
diciendo de lo que justamente está
haciendo el Banco Central que es
desincentivar el consumo a través de las
tasas altas según nuestro invitado los
bancos colombianos podrían en este
momento permitirse otorgar esos
incentivos sin perjudicar a la economía
por qué Aquí está su explicación
las decisiones que ha tomado el banco de
la República de incrementar las tasas
fueron positivas y digamos que las
acompañamos acá en anís y creemos que
era el camino para controlar la
inflación ahora ya estamos en el punto
donde vemos que la inflación está
llegando a ese pico máximo ya estamos
pues es alta era una inflación que no
veíamos en hace en los últimos dos
décadas ya estamos por el orden de 13.3%
en la inflación pero lo que nos ha
revelado el dane y recientemente es que
ya estamos llegando a ese a ese techo de
la inflación lo otro que estamos viendo
Es que por ejemplo Los indicadores de
endeudamiento de consumo de los hogares
los más recientes que tenemos ya
empiezan a mostrar que se ha reducido de
manera importante el ritmo al cual venía
creciendo Esa esa demanda interna y ese
consumo de los hogares entonces
Esperamos que eso también se refleje en
esa reducción de la inflación hacia
adelante en los próximos meses también
es que la inflación en Colombia sigue
siendo muy alta sí Andrés y la
estadística es bastante elocuente vamos
a observar en este siguiente gráfico
como las tasas del banco de la República
están actualmente en su nivel más alto
en las últimas dos décadas
específicamente un 12,75% cuando hace un
año eran del 4% y la inflación va en la
misma dirección era del 7% hace un año y
ya pasa al 13% ahora la pregunta es que
surge es si de verdad está funcionando
esta estrategia de subir intereses para
que los precios bajen o hay algo más que
se pueda hacer le preguntamos a
Alejandro chafuén quien es experto en
internacional tenés que trabajar también
por la oferta no poner trabas a la
importación permitir que haya menos haya
menos regulaciones para la gente puede
entrar al mercado aumentar el lado de la
oferta no porque qué quiere la inflación
viene cuando hay mucho más demanda que
oferta y consolidar esas demandas por
emitir dinero nuevamente no es solo la
tasa de interés Estados Unidos ha venido
reduciendo el incremento de la emisión
monetaria desde comienzo de año y de
fines de año pasado así que parte de la
baja de inflación se debe a eso así que
pero mi recomendación trabajen por el
lado de la oferta hagan más fácil a la
gente producir más
por más que parezca bajen impuestos y
van a terminar recaudando más en
conclusión a guardar esas tarjetas de
crédito Daniela habitar el consumo
desenfrenado Muchas gracias por la
información económica Daniel hablando a
nuestra editora de economía y ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
sintonizarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]